Hollywood game night it's a fun show and
II was on it last season yeah you guys
play a lot of fun games other new games
there are new games in fact there's one
that I just love it's called popped quiz
and what we do is we tell you these
silly ask you these silly little trivia
questions and if you get it wrong which
most people don't but you'll get you get
popcorn in the face
you get pop popcorn baby I'm going into
your face we've got this contraption and
you're sitting at a round table in it
but we don't have that here so your prop
people your special effect yeah they
mentioned this to me before the show I
said what is it again they went you'll
be fine fine and then I see that there
are goggles there are goggles that's
usually an indication that my life is in
danger
yes how fast is that popcorn gonna come
out of that gun you're gonna find out
very soon okay all right like I said
these are these are very very these are
easy trivia questions alright and I read
a lot I think I'll be okay yeah you'll
be good you've got like an Ivy League
education right here is your question
Conan O'Brien hub mall Sheraton and Miss
our theme our stars in which
constellation I have Aries everybody
knows that feel like you should just
shoot me because I know you're a smart
guy all right okay okay and he's good
he'll get this okay
what collective name is given to the
elements 89 through 103 on the periodic
table the Archies
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're putting it away and it went off
accidentally and almost killed me
it's they're called actinides oh yeah
yeah don't it all shout at once gang hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography